so after four years of blood sweat and
tears for more on all of those you can
check out my ox log series I finally
graduated from the University of Oxford
with a master's degree in physics
essentially making me a Time Lord being
a thousand years old much like a Time
Lord the University has quite a lot of
pomp and circumstance associated with
the graduation ceremony because the
university is collegiate ie made of
multiple colleges the first part of the
day is spent in your College which for
me with some Peters and the rest of the
day is spent in central university
buildings first thing you go to your
college you drop off your gown and you
chat your friends which you haven't seen
over the summer months I know by the way
how about the gown for the graduation
ceremony the university circulates very
particular instructions about what you
are and what you are not allowed to wear
to your graduation if you are turn up
wearing the wrong thing you're not
allowed in you don't collect your degree
for me this meant a dark suit with white
shirt white bowtie dark shoes and a gown
and later in the day a hood the
graduates gown that you wear to the
ceremony is different from the granny
wears and undergraduate so what you wear
to exams or to fall all over and you
have to hire it specifically for the
occasion you also require to hire an
academic hood which varies depending on
the degree you're going to be conferred
but generally for undergraduates it's
this white fluffy thing this only comes
into the graduation ceremony halfway
through those so it's kind of like a
mid-game substitution but more on that
later
so after you've met your friends again
and you've been introduced to their
proud parents you are shepherded into
the chapel and you're taught through how
the rest of the day works now weirdly I
was kind of nervous about this and I
wasn't alone in thinking this though
because because as I said the University
has so much pomp and circumstance it's a
ceremony it's actually it feels like a
piece of performance art more than a
celebration in some ways fortunately
those and Peters has a great dean of
degrees professor Yan Schnepp who
explained with various volunteers how
the degree ceremony works and
specifically how we are to bow to the
sequence of people who are going to
appear before us in the graduation
ceremony those people being the
vice-chancellor the registrar and the
props is now as I said the university as
a thousand years old so it's hardly
surprising but some old material is kind
of stuck around in the modern ceremony
those names for example we refer
to the chief executive officer the chief
administrative officer and the chief
disciplinarian of the university and
some of those officers have been in
continuous existence since 13th century
what's four horns and four aren't about
the ceremony we then had to get there
and this involved processing which is
walking incredibly slowly through the
center of the city dressed in your full
academic dress with your mortarboard on
this was really really surreal bringing
chaos to various shopping streets all
these people dressed in full academic
geta and parents swarming around you
taking pictures as well as several I
looking very confused are very lucky
tourists imagine from the air it looked
like a column of ants marching through
the city except there are multiple
colleges graduating on the same day so
for example for me there was some Peters
a new college he were graduating so you
had these multiple columns of academic
ants swarming through the city and
converging on the Sheldonian theater the
Sheldonian is a Central University
building which was built in 1668 based
on a design by Christopher Wren of
supports Cathedral Fame and it's used
for graduation ceremonies for certain
lectures for concerts but weirdly not
further drama directly adjacent to the
Sheldonian though is the Divinity School
which is where we were shepherded into
this was the first purpose-built room
for teaching in the university it was
also the first exam school but in 1483
it was also used for the infirmary in
the Harry Potter films and the bit in
the Goblet of Fire when they learn how
to dance they're once given a little bit
more preparation we were fired into the
Sheldonian theater now all the people
who are going to be conferred degrees
sit on this level bit at the bottom and
in the two tiers above you have parents
well-wishes and in our case several
people from our college who in the ER
below we just wanted to see the ceremony
the university officials come in and
they actually then almost work out again
I think there's some kind of procedure
where they have to check the door to
make sure it's locked or something like
that and they sit down and first of all
the doctoral candidates get their
degrees which is fair enough they've
earned then us mere mortals the
undergraduates get a shot at glory so I
was being conferred a master's degree in
physics but there are several people
from my college who were getting other
degrees as well master's degrees in math
chemistry earth sciences all those
undergraduate masters then are brought
together and followed up to the
vice-chancellor the Registrar and the
chief prop
Audino degrees professorship then takes
one of us by the hand and recites a
formula to the vice-chancellor in Latin
which goes something like this and I'm
going to apologize
I don't know Latin I've never studied it
I went to a normal school by the way the
university gives everybody one of these
to explain what earth is going on given
the most the ceremonies in Latin you
just don't have a clue what's going on
so the daily degrees will say to the
vice-chancellor something a little bit
like insignia my vice-consul are a rosca
agree Jeep rocket to Tokyo Torres
present of vobis cosmos coladas in
faculty assume would emit on tour ad
gradum buckle or a in artifice
technically II didn't actually say that
for us this is actually for the art
students because what he said was most
distinguished by his Chancellor and you
most excellent Proctor's I present to
you these my scholars in the Faculty of
Arts that they may be admitted to the
degree of Bachelor of Arts if they'd set
that at me I would have been a bit
annoyed to be honest then the Deenie
degrees steps aside leaves us to our
fate and the Vice Chancellor looks at
you all and he then proclaims to you
something a little bit like domine voz
de bitties freedom and so random statue
to approve Lidia constituted enters a
Liberty's East us University us attain
quad chrome adhesive where it is in dorm
ecology
scrutiny Liberty centimeter bit is a
quaternary nanometer business acquire
balaam middle name settles virtusphere
furmity accredited entities to which all
the candidates reply though feelin
basically what just happened was that
the graduates the university have
certain rights and privileges for
example if the university wanted to
elect a new chair of poetry we could
vote all the graduates i mean could vote
about who that person should be
essentially what the vice-chancellor is
asking us to do is to not commit
electoral fraud and to obey the statutes
and rules of the university that relates
to graduates and what we say in return
go feed em just means I swear it's
actually one piece of Latin that we have
seen the whole ceremony then the
officials dot their caps t because
they're wearing academic caps and full
academic dress the whole time and then
you're invited to file out of the side
exit at the Sheldonian theatre then you
go back to the divinity school and you
pick up your academic hoods which have
been left for you with your name on in
the divinity school you put on your
academic hood you put on your
mortarboard
and you feel very smoked because you're
like a proper university graduate now
after an excruciating wait outside the
main doors of the Sheldonian you then
see the swing open and you are invited
back into the shadow unit and everybody
in the top tiers is applauding and
there's this wonderful moment where
there's this wall of sound and
everybody's standing up and clapping and
you walk down the aisle to the
vice-chancellor who then confers on to
you your degree officially he looked
every single person in the eye and
they'll do it in rows of four or five
look every single person in the eye and
then say to them in Latin I give you the
degree master of physics and then you
again file outside X at the Sheldonian
and you wait outside for the university
officials to come file out past you all
and they'll go down the line doffing
their caps to everdene saying well done
you've got a degree and then all your
parents and stuff come out and you get
to have pictures and you do the classic
throwing the hats in the air and you go
back to your College you'll have a
typically you'll have a nice meal I got
to just juice my parents to my cheater
for the first time which was great I got
to say this is my parents it's all their
fault and at the end of the day you end
up with one of these it's strange too
hold the degree in your hands really
because in many ways for years this is
all you've been thinking about even even
thinking about the moment when you have
the degree when all your works paid off
and you actually have this thing in your
house this piece of paper which confers
to you like a passport it confers to you
the ability to get jobs it gives you
respect from people having the piece of
paper not actually having done the work
that itself is implicit in having the
piece of paper but at the end of the day
this doesn't mean anything to me I can
really care less about this piece of
paper I know that I have a university
degree I know that I have a master's
degree in physics from Oxford and the
work which went into that degree is what
gives it power to me not the end result
the things which I learned the skills
which I acquired there the things which
I really value from the university
system not the degree if you want to go
to university for one of these you're
doing it wrong you go to university for
one of these anyway that was way too
philosophical for all of my videos if
you'd let's check out my continuing
adventures here at the University of
Exeter now that I'm doing my PhD here
after graduating I recommend you stick
around on my channel subscribe I have
been loading some X logs which talk
about my life alternatively if you'd
like to learn more about the life of
University of Oxford student then I
recommend you check out my ox logs and
youtube.com forward slash ox log where
five people are continuing the vlogging
tradition I started last year five
people are doing weekly vlogs about
their lives as students so I recommend
you try those out thanks very much for
watching